the top sports stars get there with a
lot of coaching
not just physical but also psychological
i work with sports people
all the time and here are a few secrets
from the world of sports psychology
and it turns out these tricks are
equally relevant in everyday life
tip one being nervous is good
so next time you feel really nervous try
this
might sound a bit strange i promise you
it works
tell yourself i am not nervous i am
excited
why does this work well we all get
anxious and nervous at times
totally normal the tendency of course is
to tell yourself to
calm down sounds like a good idea
but having butterflies in your stomach
and that sense of anxiety
is just so far removed from a state of
calm your body just won't buy it
reframing anxiety as excitement works
because both estates have high arousal
but while
anxiety is negative and will hamper your
performance you
literally feel under threat excitement
is an emotion that will help you feel
positive and look forward to the
challenge
in the words of britain's most decorated
olympian with
six gold medals track cyclist sir chris
hoy
never use the words nervous or anxious
use the words exciting and adrenalized
tip two don't do all the work yourself
all athletes learn how to take care of
themselves
but as important as taking care of
yourself is learning to let others
support you along the way
in 2019 kenyan long-distance runner
eliot kipchoge
broke the two-hour marathon record but
he didn't do it on his own
on the day of the event he had help from
41 pacemakers
and of course the support of thousands
of people who came along to cheer
kipchoge asked for the general public to
be there because he knew he could run
better with their support who can you
ask to support you in your everyday
life there is no shame in getting help
when you're trying to achieve something
difficult
asking for support is a sign of strength
positive support is priceless
tip three mentally rehearse
many of the world's top athletes use
visualization techniques before a big
event
they're mentally rehearsing it in their
minds this can
increase motivation build confidence and
improve your performance
the more realistic this visualization
and preparation is
the more successful it will be athletes
will think about
the sounds they might hear like the
crowd
they might smell like freshly cut grass
and imagine what they're going to see
and how they might feel
runners might visualize difficult parts
of their race
before becoming the fastest british
woman in recorded history
dina russia smith had already raced and
won
multiple times in her mind she said
i might visualize the final i run
through it as if i'm running it
it's quite fun and you kind of have to
win or else there's no point
so next time you have something to
prepare for like a job interview
or an exam visualize exactly how you
would like it to go
think about what you expect to see to
smell
to hear and how it will make you feel
identify any mental challenges and how
you could overcome these
so that when you come to do it for real
you are fully prepared
tip four talk to yourself negative
thoughts reduce confidence
this happens to everyone even the
greatest athletes
but they have learned techniques to
overcome them one technique is called
self-talk
literally talking to yourself this can
have a surprising effect on your
performance
top athletes will often be heard saying
you got this
i can do this it helps them to control
anxiety
to build their confidence and provide
focus
muhammad ali often considered the
greatest boxer of all time
was famous for saying i am the greatest
but interestingly he admitted repeatedly
saying this phrase to himself
long before he became successful you
don't need to say much
use small phrases like you are ready you
are good at this
so next time your brain tells you you
can't do something
just think of muhammad ali and tell
yourself i can
you